What we've covered so far in this class is
a very simplistic and a very partial coverage of
linear regression with gradient decent. If you were ever
to try and use linear regression to solve a real
world problem, there are a lot of additional considerations
that you would want to think about in order
to seriously implement linear regression with or without gradient
descent. First of all, gradient descent is only one implementation
of linear regression. There are a bunch of other
ones, and in some sense, they may be better.
Ordinary Least Squares for example, is always guaranteed to
find the optimal solution when performing linear regression, whereas gradient
descent is not. Additionally, we haven't really talked about
parameter estimation and putting confidence intervals on those parameters. In
the models that we've built, we've given exact values
for all of our thetas. But as you can imagine,
there's some confidence that we have in those values.
You can imagine doing more thorough statistical analysis in saying
what are the confidence intervals on these parameters? And
we could answer questions like what is the likelihood that
I would get this value for this parameter if
this parameter actually had no effect on our output variable?
We also might worry about issues like over or under
fitting. This isn't so much a problem with linear regression,
but with more complicated models, you might expect our model to
over-fit. Say we had some data like these red points that
was approximately linear. If we had a model with many different
parameters, we might be able to fit the data points exactly
whereas the actual underlying model is this black line. One way
to deal with this is usually to split our data into
a training set and a test set. Then we can train
a model on the training data, and then test it on
the test data, just as the name would imply. This
is called cross validation. We might also see under-fitting, where we
have data that's clearly nonlinear, but we only try and fit
a linear model to it. This is also a problem that
you might encounter. Another issue worth mentioning again is that our
cost function may have numerous local minima. That means that when
using gradient descent, our algorithm can become trapped in a local
minimum that isn't actually the global minimum of the cost function.
This isn't a problem of other implementations of linear
regression, but when using gradient descent, this means that maybe
we perform gradient descent numerous times, randomizing our initial values
of theta with different random values every time. You may
also already know this, but when using a random
number generator to generate random values, it's important to seed
your random values and to store that seed. That way,
you have a result that's replicable and other researchers can
look at your findings and also produce them on their own machines
when they run the same script. This has been a whirlwind tour
of a bunch of additional considerations that we didn't really touch in
this lesson. These are all really
important in machine learning, statistics, using
linear regression in the real world. I really wanted to focus here
on just implementing gradient descent and the basics of how it works.
But if you really want to use any of these things to
solve a real life problem, you'd want to think about local minima,
you know other implementations of linear aggression, the confidence intervals
on your parameters and if you're using a statistical modeling package
in R or Python or Stata, they'll usually give you
these confidence intervals. And use
a reliable implementation of linear aggression.